Shantay is with us in Detroit Michigan
hey chantek how are you hi Dave how are
you better than I deserve
what's up great thank you so much for
taking my call I'm calling in because
I've read the Total Money Makeover I've
gone through FPU and I'm still in debt
after five years and one because I think
we definitely need more income coming
into our house okay what is your butcher
what's your household income $50,000
okay and how much debt did you have when
you started oh I don't remember because
we actually did a bankruptcy and so
everything was wiped out except for
student loans mm-hmm how much loan Delhi
how much how much debt do you have now
70,000 okay and you make 50 okay and the
70,000 is what all student loans no 55
of it as student loans what's the other
15 we owe 2500 left on our car a $300 a
credit card we weren't able to pay our
insurance a week-old them and we're
behind on our electric bill $2,500 I'm
still not gotten me anywhere near 15
yeah I don't medical bills as well we've
had two two kids and between there okay
so you're not living on a budget you're
not living on a plan no we are the
living on a budget I do a budget every
single week why would you be behind on
your electric bill because I don't I
don't understand you know what's going
on I don't I don't know okay
are you married yes okay does your
husband participate in this discussion
not really I keep asking him to you know
sit down do a budget with me if I okay I
trust you is your rent
we own our home how much is your payment
it's paid until it's paid off yeah and
you make $50,000 a year and he got
behind on your electric bill
exactly I how would you possibly have a
wine my limit you don't have a plan
because no one would plan to have a
paid-for house and be behind on their
light bill
that had to be done but disorganisation
yeah I mean that that can't be an
intentional organizational act to
intentionally be behind on my light bill
well that would be one of the first
things I mean so let's do a budget okay
let's lay down what your income is which
is you know you make about $4,200 a
month gross which means your take-home
pay should be in the neighborhood of
$3,500 okay that should be what you have
to work with a month coming home well
it's more like um six it's more like
wait six hundred times three and then
that's like you know it's more like
3,000 maybe 2500 in luck I don't know
why it okay we don't know how in our
income is so you're not doing a budget
you didn't tell me the truth
I know I know it per week I just don't
know it all together I don't ever do a
monthly when I do a weekly one right
well you're supposed to be doing a
monthly one and ER and the way you have
to do it monthly and you have to do it
weekly okay the first thing you buy out
of your budget is food right the second
thing you buy is utilities uh-huh before
you do anything else the third thing you
buy his house payment you don't have
house payments all you've got insurance
and taxes to keep from losing it okay
and and so all you're doing is you're
making a solid list here of where your
money is going to go every week and you
make the money go that way and you grab
a Bubba by the ear and you drag him to
the table and sit him down and say man
up I need some help
I've been working on this five years I
feel like a rat in a wheel and I need
your help we're going to work on this
together we're going to fix this okay
all right because you know you're not
making a ton of money but you're like
you said you're getting further behind
in the reason you're getting further
behind is you haven't done any of the
things we taught you in Financial Peace
University oh you're not doing your
written budget you're not working
together with your husband you're not
prioritizing your spending I know this
because of the the data you've just
given me in
conversation I'm not fussing at you but
I'm coaching you uh-huh you called me so
you knew this was coming I knew even get
it to feel like it like a new here so
that's fine I'm sold I got my arm around
you but I'm gonna take your bud okay you
know what we keep having vehicle issues
too that's another thing unexpected that
you know because we have a $2,500 truck
that we keep having to pump money into
the other vehicle that we're still we
still owe money on the engine doesn't
work so we can't even use it but we're
still paying for it we need to develop a
game plan for each one of these things
and start addressing them as we can
address them as fast as we can address
them but you don't ever need to be
behind on your food or your lights again
when you make $50,000 a year and you
don't have a house payment ever I don't
know how to get caught up on it now like
I said how much do you owe me five
twenty five hundred okay well I don't
know how to get caught up a thousand
this month and 1500 next month okay
because its first somebody else may not
get paid but by god the lights are
getting paid right I'm gonna pay them
you're going to eat and we're going to
catch the lights up in the next two
months and we're gonna pay a few of
these other things but that's about it
because you can't have your dadgum
utilities cut off kiddo right no I know
I guess you know and because here's what
happens fart one little thing he breaks
like the car and then there's a medical
thing and then there's another thing and
then there's another thing and then
there's another thing
and these crisises start piling up and
they've gotten piled so high now that
we're down to we don't pay the lights
and so what ends up happening is you
have so much freakin stress on Whichard
in the situation you're describing that
it paralyzes you mm-hmm if you were
doing for someone if if you walked up to
someone else you went through Financial
Peace University five years ago if one
of your friends came over and dumped a
shoebox of bills in your on your kitchen
table you could work right through their
situation because you're not stressed
out about their situation and you're
smart enough to do math I mean this is
not heart there's not a sixth grade math
you can do it but but the problem is
you've just been carrying this all by
yourself emotionally because your
husband's not been participating
it's gotten disorganized and stress upon
stress upon stress upon stress following
a bankruptcy following two kids I mean
it's just piled up on you and you
paralyzed you and so so you ended up
because of the desperation making some
bad decisions and that's just that
doesn't mean you're dumb it just means
you're a human so it's time to get
organized and split this up and say okay
are we going to eat this elephant a bite
at a time
we got to address these truck this truck
we got to address this yet light bill we
got to get these medical bills go
straight now which ones first which ones
second which ones third who's working
extra let's have a garage sale what are
we doing let's get back in Financial
Peace University and get our batteries
charged again go back through it's free
go back through you and your husband get
a class started I'll put you on hold
Kelly I'll help you find a class you get
plugged back into a class and if you
need a new kit or something to plug back
in because it's sound like you went
through an older system we'll put you
back in again I want you to I want you
to win but you're going to have to grab
this thing by the throat and choke it
until you get it under control because
it's whipping you right now and it's
time for you to get back on top and
start winning again
I mean you this thing's got its got its
foot on your neck and it's time for you
to say no no money you're going to
behave money you're going to do what I
tell you to do and if somebody doesn't
get paid this month because we're
working something that's more important
well so be it can't pay that medical
bill this month why because I'm broke
that's why I paid other stuff that was
more important than you and that's what
you tell them and you'll get to them
you'll get to them and you'll get by by
out there with some overtime and some
other people with some extra jobs and
you'll start selling a car with the
engine that doesn't work and you'll have
a garage sale and you get on a dadgum
track and you can you can crack the whip
on this and turn it around but this is
about you leaning into the details in
the process so hold on Kelly he'll pick
up and I'll tell you what else I'm gonna
do Kelly um hook her up she needs
somebody help her unpack this see if
we've got a coach in the area if we got
a coach in the area I'll pay for that
too we'll pay for the coach to sit down
with her and help her unpack but huh
Bubba's got to come husband's got to
come okay I'm not playing with her just
doing it by herself they both got to be
in the game they're both in the game
I'll pay for the coach too
that's the deal hold on this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim